philip morris how is that the number one
story of business since
until apparently gerard told us 711 came
and took it away from them
philip morris international ceo says
cigarettes should be banned and the
company will stop selling marlboros in
the uk within a decade business insider
store the ceo
of phillip moore's the maker of marble
cigarettes outside of the us said his
company will stop selling
cigarettes in the uk within a decade ceo
jackie
ozak said on sunday that the move was
part of the company's goal to become
smoke free and to help
end the use of traditional cigarettes he
also called the uk government to outlaw
cigarettes within a decade comparing
them to
gas empowered cars and they're set to be
barred
from being sold in the country starting
2030 philip morris international
separate from philip moore's usa
which makes marbles in the u.s smoking
kills more than eight million people a
year according to a
world health organization did you just
hear that yeah
smoking kids this is the most confusing
story
so you're just shooting yourself in the
foot and ruining your own business model
like so basically you're saying you're
switching the weed boys
that's like what like what are you doing
what are you going all in on that weed
jules yeah uh this is big tobacco
basically saying guys
everything we've been doing for the last
hundred years or so bad
our bad bad smoking actually kills all
the disclaimers and labels
go ahead and pay attention to those what
the hell is going on i'm gonna be fine
i'm gonna be for real i i
i had a i had like a a 12 year chewing
tobacco habit so and
and i got to tell you i i valued my
health so i stopped but oh man is it
good
oh man there's just nothing like
throwing a little lipper in in the
morning getting yourself the morning
paper and having
having your morning constitution all
that black trash my name is gerard how
you doing
put a little whipper and i think it's
funny i think it's funny is how that my
kids are gonna grow up with legal weed
and have to buy their tobacco from a
drug dealer
man look you think people are going to
stop smoking cigarettes is there
anything yeah i mean
look i'm sorry for the kids they're
listening to this you guys can hate me
all you want but i
look there's nothing better than than
after a couple beers on a friday night
having yourself a dart
you know i'm just it is what it is man i
look you can you can do the natty
spirits it's
those are all natural it's basically
like having a vegetable kids but no
listen if you want to know anything
about cigarettes just watch uh thank you
for smoking it's one of the best movies
nobody's ever heard of
if you've never started smoking don't do
it if you've never started chewing
don't do it it is addicting but if you
think tobacco is going away after all
these years
i mean literally tobacco was so powerful
the addiction was so powerful
that an entire continent moved to
another continent to farm it okay go to
pmi.com
go to pmi.com this is pmi.com okay you
go to pmi philipmores international.com
you go to the bottom pmi product sells
and over 180 markets and many of these
we hold the number one or number two
position by market share six of the top
15 international brands
in the world are ours right there big
boat the number one cigarette brand
since
1972. the marlborough so here's what i'm
wondering
what products do they sell look at the
number right there in 2019 marble volume
outside the united states and china was
260 billion cigarettes reinforcing its
leadership position as the number one
cigarette brand worldwide
i just want to know what's 30 cigarettes
that's a person what's in the world by
the way what's his response the ceo that
basically said we're
stop smoking i i love the analogy they
made that cigarettes are now basically
like the gas-powered cars
so they're going electric so all right
there's some light bulbs should be going
on everything's going electric electric
now they're going jewel with the great
yeah it's all about the jewels you will
you will own nothing yeah be happy it's
all about the jewels or vapes
i was just rolling loud this weekend you
wouldn't believe how many kids are
vaping yeah
v it's a big hip-hop you vape or no no
i've never
no if i'm gonna if i'm gonna if i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do the real thing
people don't know
adam sauce is actually 72 years old not
a single wrinkle
about a single wrinkle he's actually 72.
thank you bro yeah yeah i'm a vampire
have you has anybody ever seen pat in
direct sunlight no
he's been saying this by the way behind
your back he's he's been going about
he go i go yeah what about you know
sleep july 4th we were at his house at
barbecue
he was in the shade the whole time he
was in the shade
i don't know about it all right so
anyway but maybe maybe just maybe
they're going to go in the weed
direction they're getting out of those
cigarettes go weed with it
bro look i i go the different direction
i go okay what's next is
you know is lays going to come out and
be like look there's fried potatoes it's
bad
bad thing here's a question for you okay
let's let's judge a little bit is that
okay let's judge a little bit let's play
the judgment game
here we go no no here we go you ready
let's judge kai you ready or not
okay tell me what an nhl fan
the profile of an nhl fan give me the
profile of an nhl fan
they are a white man in their 50s
and they are they love uh actually
canada girls they love okay they love
canada
you're into an nhl game you're right are
probably nhl fans all right
i'm gonna be a hockey fan let's continue
judging give me give me the profile of
an nfl fan
you're looking at him right here there
he is yeah
he's checking for the bill he's checking
his fantasy football score
all right let me give you guys a grown
man
let's let's continue give me the profile
of somebody who watches
tennis oh
rob r style who watches tennis they like
they like headbands and
long white socks yeah danielle
daniella the romanian yeah okay so let's
go to another give me a profile of
somebody
who goes to every single
nightclub five nights a week and listens
to edm 24 7. got themselves
profile of that guy they're a guy or
girl i'm thinking girls okay girls
give me the profile well give me that
they're a 25 year old bottle waitress
type of a girl
and you know they like wearing uh hyper
colors and they they're down to party
okay give me the profile of
somebody give me the profile of somebody
who's a hardcore crypto bitcoin like
it's
all about cryptocurrency give me the
profile who is the person whether they
love
david thank you who they're a
young man in their 20s ish
um that has hasn't really made real
money yet okay
give me the profile of somebody give me
the profile of somebody who drinks jose
cueva tequila
[Music]
i'm looking at it i look at it an older
tequila drinker
okay young people i would say ricardo
can t
ricardo uh could drink jose cuervo and
not even get buzzed
all right give me the profile of
somebody who drinks uh
louis the what is it 13 16. whatever the
13. i don't know any of those people pat
you're going to have to answer that one
so somebody rich europeans
rich europeans fair because you know
some of those guys you party with those
guys so expensive
watch this but of course let's have a
couple of dreams
profile of a pothead who smokes weed
every day
[Music]
got a weird beard going on got a weird
beard going kind of like a ratty beard
maybe
they're from norway all right so
so let's continue give me what we're
doing is being prejudiced i'm about to
get to the water
give me the profile of somebody who
smokes cigarettes
they got a raspy voice and their grandma
no they were just born in china
that smokes a pack a day give me a give
me a profile of somebody that's almost a
package
six 60 70 year olds that have smoked
since they were 12. yeah they've been
smoking for 30 years leathery skin
yeah they can look like a catcher's mitt
used car old used cars hands hands
feel weird you have a [ __ ] who shook
their hands like hands fuels were like a
dry skin
they got sandpaper european european
so if you know well european smoker's a
lot different than american smoker
uh you have a drink and there's smoke
it's okay it's good look you have my
baguette and my little
front two t three yellow yeah yeah
yellow yellow
okay there you go so i mean listen
there's the profile of a cigar smoker
what's this yeah matzapala but what is
the profile of a cigar smoker
money a little more a little a little
wealthier
i don't understand man from the
libertarian standpoint you want to smoke
cigarettes go at it right i mean i grew
up in a family where everybody smokes
cigarettes from the day i was born until
i remember when my dad finally had a
heart attack went to the hospital had
his open heart surgery so last time he
smoked cigarettes 1993.
i don't understand smoking cigarettes i
understand beer i understand tequila i
understand whiskey i understand cigar i
understand wheat i don't understand
cigarettes
let me say something yeah let me say
something please what i don't understand
what torches what i don't understand
about cigarettes yeah
are daytime smokers where you're waking
up
you're having a like listen helicopter
salesman car salesman helicopter
fingertips yellow
listen i will say this this guy says pat
i'm i'm smoking cigarettes drinking beer
and watching this podcast india
way to go right raheed
listen america you might frown upon this
it doesn't happen all right here we go
but if you're not sex if you're drunk
and you're having a nice time and some
lovely girls over there
and and and you say hey we could share a
cigarette together icebreaker it's a
bonding moment and it's an icebreaker
and it's a power move yeah so am i
waking up
at you know 7 a.m like time for a
cigarette
but if it's 2 a.m and you're a little
buzzed and you're out and about
and a pretty girl's right there and need
a light boom i'm sure
i'm sure this was marketing but all
movies and tvs in the 80s 70s 80s 90s
i you know i i thought that that was
like a thing you were supposed to like
when you pack a cigarette
by the way i know i know the first time
i smoked a cigarette was to impress a
girl
okay how old were you seven or what was
your uh i was i just turned ten
no um two years ago for people that
don't know
okay funny i will say this i'm not
encouraging smoking
but if the the fellas out there want a
easy layup move to get
you know if a girl's sitting there don't
don't share a cigarette
you're not your sheriff you're going
back and forth it's in your mouth it's
in her mouth
you guys are sharing a cigarette i'm
just saying
you're gonna do it it's in her mouth
it's in my mouth who knows what's going
on i wasn't going there i'm just saying
that that it is abominable
we're learning a lot about you today
you're not doing that with the cigar
though what about the hookah smoker
what's going to happen to the hookah
smokers man what's the profile
what's what's the profile of the lucas
hookah smoker my middle eastern friend
26 year old armenian
you know maybe named tigrin
with the perfect beard you know yeah and
uh
every sentence starts with bro
brother brother brother that's like
that's a lid
bro bro so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye